RECORDED LANDFALL IN THE U.S.
NOW BACK TO THE "INGRAHAM
ANGLE."
>> IT'S FRIDAY.
THAT MEANS IT'S TIME FOR --
THE WORST MEDIA 34E89DOWN
FOLLOWING THE MUELLER REPORT,
MIC DROP MOMENT AND TWO HIT 70s
SITCOMS COMING BACK TO TV.
"NEW YORK TIMES" BEST-SELLING
AUTHOR.
THE NEW WILL WILDER BOOK, THE AM
YOU LEAPT OF POWER.
WHAT WERE SOME OF THE ODDEST
MOMENTS IN THE MEDIA ATMOSPHERE
YESTERDAY.
>> LAURA, IN THE WAKE OF THE
MUELLER REPORT, SOME LIKE
RACHAEL MADDOW, FOR INSTANCE,
SPENT HALF OF THE SHOW JUST
READING THE REPORT.
IT WAS LIKE READING RAINBOW FOR
THE POLITICALLY OBSESSED.
WATCH.
>> THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
INTERFERE IN THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IN
SWEEPING AND SYSTEMATIC FASHION.
QUOTE, THE SPECIAL COUNSEL --
>> MARCH 18, 2016, THE IRA
PURCHASED AN ADVERTISEMENT
DEPICTING CANDIDATE CLINTON IN A
CAPTION READING -- HE REQUESTED
TO MEMBERS OF HIS CAMPAIGN THAT
THEY NEEDED TO FIGURE OUT WAYS
TO FIND CLINTON'S E-MAILS.
>> I LIKE HER READING STUFF.
I LIKE -- I'D LISTEN TO A BOOK.
>> I'M A BIG ADVOCATE OF READING
ALOUD, PARTICULARLY TO KIDS.
BUT VICE TOOK IT A STEP FORWARD.
THEY READ THE ENTIRE REPORT IN
JUST UNDER 12 HOURS.
LAURA.
LOOK AT THE BEAUTIFUL PICTURES
THEY PROVIDED THERE.
THERE WERE DRAMATIC MOMENTS,
LAURA.
ONCE THE REPORT DROPPED, CHRIS
CUOMO AND MAJOR GIULIANI WERE
ONE FOR THE AGES.
THE WORD OF THE DAY WAS LIE!
>> IF I WANT TO KNOW IF YOU WILL
APOLOGIZE ON THE PART OF THE
PRESIDENT FOR DENYING RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE ALL ALONG.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO BE KIDDING ME.
>> I'M SAYING THAT THE PRESIDENT
LIED?
>> THE PRESIDENT DID NOT LIE.
HE DID NOT HAVE A BUSINESS
DEAL --
>> WHY DOES HE --
>> WHY DID THE PRESIDENT LIE
ABOUT IT?
>> THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T LIE
ABOUT IT.
HE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT.
>> WHY DID THE PRESIDENT --
>> WOULD YOU PLEASE STOP USING
THE WORD "LIE" WHEN YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> THEY'RE FRIENDS.
>> WHEN YOU'RE SO WEDDED TO A
NARRATIVE AND IT FALLS APART
WITH A REPORT, YOU GET THIS
REACTION, JOE DIGENOVA POPPED UP
ON "HILL TV," THE HOST THERE
SAID BILL BARR MAY HAVE LIED.
>> YOU HAVE NO EVIDENCE THAT HE
LIED.
AND YOU KNOW IT.
>> BUT I'M TELLING YOU.
>> YOU SAID HE MAY HAVE LIED.
>> WHAT I'M TELLING YOU IS WHAT
HE SAID TODAY IN THE PRESS
CONFERENCE IS INCONSISTENT WITH
WHAT'S IN OUR --
>> THAT'S NOT A LIE.
>> THAT'S -- OKAY.
FINE.
>> IT'S NOT FINE.
YOU'RE ON NATIONAL TELEVISION
CALLING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL A
LIAR.
>> I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
>> YOU SUGGESTED IT VERY
STRONGLY.
>> ALL RIGHT, I THINK WE'RE DONE
HERE.
>> I THINK WE ARE.
>> WHEW!
JOE DIGENOVA BROUGHT OUT THE
GLOVES.
IS MADDOW STILL READING?
>> ENCRYPTED APPLICATIONS.
WITHOUT THEM BEING ABLE TO TRACK
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE CONTRACT.
>> THE PROSECUTOR'S JUDGMENT
THAT CRIMES WERE COMMITTED BUT
NO CHARGES WILL BE BROUGHT
AFFORDS NO --
>> THE PRESIDENT'S MESSAGE TO
SESSIONS HE SHOULD COP FINE THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION TO ONLY
FUTURE ELECTION MEDDLING.
>> [SNORING].
>> OH, SORRY.
>> I LIKE HER READING.
SHE HAS A GREAT --
>> SHE SHOULD DO AUDIOBOOKS.
>> I HAVE TO ASK YOU ABOUT BILL
BARR'S PRESS CONFERENCE.
I THINK -- I GOT ALL OF THESE
TWEETS, TEXTS, WHY WAS IT WHAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM SOME OF THE
MALCONTENTS, WHY WAS IT
EFFECTIVE?
>> BARR TAKES YOGA.
HE'S COOL AND EVEN.
HE'S THE GEORGE FOREMAN OF
LAWYERS.
HE TAKES A PUNCH, HE JUST STANDS
THERE.
WATCH THE EXCHANGE.
HE HAD WITH CBS'S PAUL REED WHO
CHALLENGED HIM OVER WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT FACED AP UNPRECEDENTED
SITUATION IN THE RUSSIAN PROBE.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A LOT
OF EFFORT TO -- TO
ACKNOWLEDGE --
>> IS THERE ANOTHER PRECEDENT
FOR IT?
>> NO.
>> SO UNPRECEDENTED IS AN
ACCURATE DESCRIPTION, ISN'T IT?
>> YEAH.
>> OKAY.
>> COULD YOU IMAGE IF ANY JEFF
SESSIONS WERE HERE.
YOU CAN SENSE BARR'S FRUSTRATION
WENT ON AS THE REPORTERS ASKED
INCREASINGLY RIDICULOUS
QUESTIONS ALL LEADING TO THIS
MIC DROP MOMENT.
>> IMPROPRIETY FOR YOU TO COME
OUT AND SORT OF SPIN THE REPORT
BEFORE THE PUBLIC GETS THE
CHANCE TO READ IT?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> NOPE.
BYE-BYE.
HE JUST WALKS AWAY.
I LOVE THE WALK-OFF.
HE DOESN'T EVEN SAY GOOD-BYE.
HE SAID DO YOU FEEL YOU'RE
SPINNING THIS.
NOPE, AND HE'S GONE.
IT'S A GREAT MOMENT.
>> HE SHOULD HAVE DROPPED THE
ACTUAL MIC.
>> YOU MAY REMEMBER "ALL IN THE
FAMILY," THE "THE JEFFERSONS,"
ABC SAID THEY'RE GOING TO AIR A
LIVE CLASSIC EPISODE WITH EACH
OF THOSE SHOWS WITH AN ALL-STAR
CAST.
WOODY HARRELLSON AND MARISA
TOMEI WILL PLAY ARCHIE AND EDITH
BUNKER AND JAMIE FOXX WILL PLAY
GEORGE JEFFERSON.
DO YOU BELIEVE THIS IS GOING TO
WORK, LAURA?
>> I DON'T LIKE TINKERING WITH
THE BEST.
AND THAT -- THOSE SHOWS
AND THAT -- THOSE SHOS WERE
AMONG THE BEST EVER PRODUCED.
>> I CONDUCTED THE LAST
INTERVIEW WITH CAROL O'CONNOR.
HE TALKED ABOUT WHY IT WORKED.
THIS IS WHY I THINK THIS NEW IT
RATION WILL NOT.
WATCH?
>> YOU CANNOT LAUGH AT THE
CHARACTER YOU'RE PLAYING.
YOU CANNOT BE AWARE THAT HE'S
FUNNY.
AS AN ACTOR.
YOU HAVE TO PLAY INTENTIONALLY
AND YOU HAVE TO PLAY HIM
FIERCELY AND ANGRILY AND THAT'S
WHAT MAKES HIM FUNNY.
>> HE WAS A CLASSIC.
I THINK WE'RE AFRAID OF THIS
MATERIAL TODAY.
AND I DOUBT IF AN ACTOR IS GOING
TO PLAY HIM THROUGH.
I THINK THEY'LL COMMENT ON HIM,
WHICH WILL NOT WORK.
>> MAD THAT BUNKER ENDED UP
BEING SO --
>> SYMPATHETIC.
>> AND PEOPLE DIDN'T LIKE MEAT
HEAD.